did you watch all of Naruto then or did
you read that at some point so I watched
up to most of Shippuden yeah
um and that was most of it okay so was
it like the did you get to the fourth
ninja war Arc at all because that's when
I started
um I don't know if I did because so I
watched a lot when I was like really
really young and I'd go to uh so the
anime wasn't so big back then yeah what
would happen is you would buy ripped
burned CDs from the local scuffed DVD
store here
my uncle owned the store
um and that's where I would get it from
and I would get like Naruto episode one
to ten Super Late by the way like you
wouldn't see it weekly yeah um and I
just watched the original Naruto way
back in the day oh yeah that's you know
it's very similar to what how I first
started Naruto actually I bought my
first ever first purchased it was with
anime was uh on eBay and I thought I was
getting an official DVD oh it was just
Birds DVDs yeah
it was just a CD folder with burnt CDs
on it and that's how I got that's how I
go into anime I'd rather that than
subscribe to Peacock streaming I'll say
that much the same same I rather have
them like sub espanol part eight okay
wait I used to watch that on YouTube
because they for some reason they
wouldn't get mad at the Spanish subbed
one for some reason I don't know why
those are the only ones that existed the
YouTube like yeah I'll survive how could
you read the subs
um you kind of couldn't but you would
sometimes the the they would have the
added captions
or someone in the comments
but I did take Spanish in high school so
I could sort of understand some okay but
a lot of times it was just like just see
what happens and you can kind of tell
from the pictures there's a lot of
Spanish in California a lot of Spanish
like you just see Spanish yeah Spanish
TV it's quite common like um at least in
La yeah every school would be like well
at least my school would be like you
have to learn a foreign language they
recommend Spanish because there's is a
lot of Spanish right right that makes
sense that makes sense I mean for us it
was French mostly uh I took Spanish in
high school as well though I've
forgotten all of it so please please use
uh useless to me right now yeah yeah did
you have to do anything in uh Australian
like what's what's on the Australian
curriculum uh so it depends on the
school but my score only offered one
language and it was Japanese well that's
awfully and I'm like well um
yeah I literally said that's so strange
really yes it was only Japanese and it's
like I mean again it depends on the
school because like a lot of like the
other schools in the area were offering
like you know the standard like Spanish
and French and you know all that kind of
stuff yeah but for some reason our
school was like only Japanese
and I was like uh okay so I would just
sit in the back of the class and you
know they'd be teaching them like
standard like you know IU or only here
and stuff and it's like I was just
seeing I was just sitting in the back of
the classroom made you turn up to that
yeah I had to turn up because it was it
was in year eight it was a compulsory
subject that speaks better than the
teacher
like I did yeah I literally had moments
where the teacher would be teaching me
something would teaching the class
something and then just every now and
they'll be like that was correct right
Joey and I'm like yeah yeah
I'm getting paid for this right you're
like yes goes back to playing like Final
Fantasy yeah I was just playing on my DS
the whole time oh it was great you guys
got another recording today yep yeah
it's gonna be absolutely Juiced packed
up because you got someone coming soon
right yeah yeah yeah yeah I think well
that sounds
almost here I think yeah yeah Sons
if he ended his stream he's on the way
here okay an absolute workaholic there's
no chance he's dawdling around somewhere
okay kind of a little worrying but you
know some stream is just like that
they've just Min matched he gets to
where he is by working like that yeah I
respect I couldn't I couldn't imagine
yeah that's why I could never be a
twitch streamer oh that's I went to a
YouTube uh Summit thing right that I was
invited to because you know YouTube
contracted me yeah and like I I think we
were the only few you know streaming is
not huge on YouTube yeah compared to
Twitch
um so like I went there and I noticed
the biggest difference between talking
to streamers and YouTubers they actually
take breaks like I feel like for me
um I'm taking like eight days off
streaming yeah absolutely insane like
nobody does that yeah um it's just crazy
to do that usually I'll take one day off
maybe yeah um maybe one day off a week
is that why you haven't is this why this
is the first time you've traveled
outside the country
um well that's just because I didn't
have a passport and I never found a
reason to oh yeah I feel like streamers
don't take many days off yeah especially
you can't you are you are like locked in
that grind because I mean I've like
tried you know several parts to like
tried streaming more and then I realized
if I just take like one week break your
viewership just halves yeah like yeah
it's not good for that um and you lose a
lot of your subs that's a lot of your
Revenue too so it's just bad off
viewership down yeah Revenue down
everything down yeah
um and also you just know you're not
because like I know a lot of streamers
when I talk to them they're like when I
have the stream on money's going I'm
making money yeah yeah so it's very easy
to be like why am I not doing that why
am I not monetizing this one yeah like I
can turn this on and yeah I get paid and
I got bills to pay everything yeah so I
feel like it's very easy for streamers
to just be like oh I could do that today
yeah and make a certain amount of money
like I know some people who uh will be
like I make this amount of money every
day yeah and if they take a day off
they'll be like I just lost some amount
of of money like and they'll be and
they'll just feel bad about it and it'll
bother them I think it's hard to like
get away from the mindset it's the I
find it's a really unhealthy mindset
that's why yes what the man is outside
Hassan's outside yeah okay
um and I feel like that's why it's so
easy just to get caught in like stream a
burnout I feel like it's way more
prevalent than extremely calm yeah
because even taking a day off you feel
super a lot of YouTubers that I met
there like I make a video every few
months and then the rest of the time I'm
doing whatever and I'm like oh wow
that's that's pretty nice yeah yeah like
I've gone I've gone down to like a video
or at most two videos like a month and
I'm like yeah it's pretty good yeah hey
have you guys met Michael before
um yeah yeah he'll make a video maybe
once once a year yeah he's doing great
but every video is a [__] Banger man
you know and his views very hard on yeah
every every time he uploads a video
reviews are always banging is always
one of the content creators I watch
every video he makes yeah yeah which is
a low effort commitment because it's
once a year
it's like Christmas yeah exactly I love
his videos though for sure yeah yeah
what'd you do on holiday
you take a break what'd you do you don't
take breaks yeah he's always he's always
live yeah that's that's why I mean I'm
not as bad as design yeah say that
um I do think moving to YouTube helped a
lot right now I get paid you know like
can't say too much obviously but yeah
yeah now I get paid no matter what like
I'll make enough where I don't have to
be like I'm not streaming this day I'm
not making this money that I might I
might need it for something or something
right
um so I think moving to YouTube let me
do a lot of things where I can be like I
don't have to stream this day I still
got to do it like you still don't feel
it but it's like did you count this is a
holiday that's all
I'd like to but my body's telling me
otherwise because we've been getting up
at like 6 A.M
we come back you saw us at that dinner
Ray was like falling asleep yeah yeah
like Hassan's still kind of alive
because he was hopped up on coffee and
stuff like the rest of us are like guys
work yeah I can't wait to go back after
eating yeah raise like if I drink a sip
of alcohol I'm on a KO like I'm so tired
um it was um yeah so it's like sort of
yeah I mean it definitely was fun I
enjoyed it do you want to travel more at
all like I want to come back to Japan
actually I know there's so much we
didn't get to do oh yeah yeah you'll
have such a short time you should
definitely come back and try it and we
missed our first day because of the
delays right right
exactly like I feel like you've spent
all the time in Tokyo and rightly so
there's enough to do to like put your
time in just purely Tokyo but there's so
much of Japan that's interesting as well
yeah and you know there's stuff to do
huh compared to like La there's stuff to
do oh yeah go around and do things well
there's stuff to do as well in like
close proximity to everything yeah you
can just go to it I'm like wow I could
like go somewhere new every week yeah if
you lived here for example yeah you can
work and stuff and then every weekend or
something I don't know maybe not
weekends usually so this is a pro pro
content creator tip yeah just don't go
out on the weekends because that's when
all the regular people go yeah always go
out on like a week day when you're like
on a Monday that's my first week doing
content creation yeah you wouldn't
believe it but a lot of people like um
are just we were booking a vacation in
uh Big Bear yeah uh recently we just got
it a weekend instinctively because
that's normally what you do yeah there's
there's so much traffic uh I didn't even
get to ski because it was packed and I
was like guys why did we come here on a
weekend
just showed up at any time like on a
Monday at midnight and like absolutely
had no one to you know like you know be
crowded with I think the only thing that
happens when you I guess uh maybe become
a I noticed when you become a big
influencer or whatever you want to call
it
um you still kind of do have this weird
notion of weekends are kind of a bit
more free because more often not maybe
your Asian is trying to contact you
throughout the week and you say hey I
got this deal you should oh man let me
tell you I'm the least uh I believe that
I believe it all my friends have like
assistance they have like teams I'm like
I'm just the dude who just plays games
so I'm very not uh not very professional
this is so funny because when I was
talking to YouTube about them buying me
yeah um
you know what I mean right there and
then I was just like
um yeah I don't really have they're like
so do you have any crazy plans coming up
and I'm like no I'm probably just gonna
keep playing games and they're like okay
okay
um do you want any help doing things and
I'm like now I was just gonna play some
more Among Us and like some other games
and they're like okay do you what what
kind of content do you want to make and
I was like I'm just gonna play games
with my friends and then I don't know if
that hurt my negotiation at all but I'm
definitely like not as you know
professional I don't know I'm not like a
real content creator I just you just go
with the floor right yeah I kind of just
played games maybe some would argue that
makes you even a realer content creator
you are so nice Connor I don't know
about that just wait we gotta we gotta
have more food and drinks
I'm being nice now that's always says
nice things about you
that's true that's true he does
everybody does actually yeah I've
definitely been enjoying my weekends
more I've had to learn as a content
creator how to enjoy my weekends uh no
it's it's no it's true generally when
you when you fast when you first start
you're like I can work any day and then
take a break any day but the point is I
feel still like it feels weird taking
breaks on weekdays you know because
everyone else is grinding and I you just
feel like I could be I could be working
right now because everyone else is
working you see like the messages from
your agency and people are still in the
office and you just like doesn't feel
like a proper break but especially like
you know you know making friends who
aren't content creators as well
especially and hang out with them you
I've learned to appreciate my weekends
more because it feels like nobody's
working now so yeah I don't feel guilty
for not working as well even just seeing
messages about work and sometimes drag
you back into that kind of work mindset
so yeah that kind of ruins if you had a
good vibe going on you're like damn it I
gotta stop what I'm doing or reply to it
anymore
the game is the work
um